if you haven't heard we have a new
ramsey personality dr. john de Loney and
you're gonna be hearing a whole lot more
one of his two PhDs is in counseling and
so we thought it would be good for John
to coach some of you guys on how to talk
to yourself about the anxiety the fear
that's out there how to talk to your
family about it you might be in a
leadership role we were talking about it
off air during the breaks on the stuff
you know some stuff I'm having to do as
the leader in this organization right
now and you know how to talk to others
yourself others if you want if you want
to deal with that the phone number here
if you've got questions for dr. D this
is your time the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so John talk about anxiety versus
fear we were talking about the other day
and I loved your take on it
so anxiety is just an alarm system right
it's just the fire alarm that could go
off at any moment when it smells smoke
right and you often hear about folks
with an anxiety disorder that that just
means the alarms busted right and we've
all been in the building when the fire
alarms going off and you can't you can't
check your email and they say they don't
leave the building don't leave the
building but the fire alarms are going
off your brains fried there you go from
the hearing fear is that's something
you're experiencing right now the
building you look out the window and you
see flames that's that's fear that's for
real right and so I think what we're
seeing across the country is fears real
and if you're not scared if you're not
scared on that you think people
overreacting you're not scared that
we're all gonna die from this virus
you're not scared about fill in the
blank
you're not scared that you have ten kids
at your house now that we're supposed to
be in school right then I think
something's wrong with you right yes
you'd be feeling something you should
feel some angst there you go
some level of fear so good fear is there
and then you know that keeps you from
touching a hot stove it causes you to
analyze and use your critical thinking
skills and really lean into a situation
absolutely which is what we're doing
with right now you might have a
financial situation you might have a
career mess right now you might have a
health mess right now but and so fear in
those situations are smart over
correcting with fear what I've been
calling hysteria and it might not be
clinically the correct term but I'm
calling it hysteria which is people that
are just afraid they're they're in panic
mode the difference in fear and panic
talk about that panic is the response
right it's screaming and yelling and
running out the door and the only thing
that you're gonna do when you scream and
yell and or not the door is trip your
neighbor knock over their lighter so
they fit the building off it just panic
solves nothing it solves nothing
and it takes a situation and compounds
it makes it worse yeah everybody my the
guy who trained me in crisis counseling
dr. Andy young used to always tell us
before we went into a situation calm is
contagious you walk into a situation and
you're running and screaming you just
take everybody else's temperature up
with you walk in assess the situation
slow down bring the room down and then
you can make good decisions I had a
almost 22 years old I was working for a
guy we were building custom homes and he
used that technique in a little
different way if we had a customer that
was irate and sat down the office the
louder they got the quieter he got
that's right the louder they got the
more he lowered the octave in his voice
intentionally was this became it was his
luck Chris Hogan is real quiet and calm
and it just it what it does it just
sucks the drama out of the air my dad
was a hostage negotiator he used to
drive me crazy when he did that to me as
a kid right I'd come in all freaked out
and he would just kind of bring it down
bring it down that's right yeah a volume
down and the octave down and the pulse
rate down and then because no one makes
good decisions with their panic that's
right and when were when we experience
fear naturally it's wired into us we
starts again in the environment for fear
and now we're in a world where there is
no shortage of people trying to sell us
fear and so it's coming on our phones
it's beeping on a wrist it's on our TVs
it's on it's on it's everywhere and it
really contagious it since
clinically so right and so it's how do
you turn the noise off how do you turn
it down bring it down a notch and I
think some of the times what happens is
and we when I was talking to our team
yesterday I was describing to them that
the idea that that the physiological
response to fear and anger is pretty
close the same things happen to your
body in both cases you know you have the
same your eyes dilate you have a protein
endorphin release and adrenaline release
your heart rate changes
you know so fear and anger feel hmm a
lot of like they are cousins aren't they
I think physiologically you can say that
that's fair yeah and then just how we
choose to name it in those situations
whether you're what's your default
mechanism is my default is anger
my wife's default is fear I've got a
good friend whose default is fear and
that doesn't mean anything it doesn't
mean you're a fearful person or an angry
person it just means that that's that's
how you interpret a situation how you
choose to go at it if you don't stop and
breathe and wisdom is knowing what my
default setting is catching myself
before I do something and surrounding
myself with smart people who know that's
my default setting right I got a group
of guys in my life who know I'm about to
they'll roll their eyes and say hasta
Loney right they know they know where
I'm about to head with something and
they're there to kind of rein me back in
yeah the phone number if you want to
talk to dr. Dee about these things that
are going on in the marketplace triple 8
8 to 5 5 2 to 5 triple 8 8 to 5 5 to 25
one of you is going to be the first call
he ever takes in his radio career you
have that opportunity right now that's
like winning the sweepstakes right there
I'm gonna yeah in that I don't know what
that wins yeah
so in most situations in my experience
when the threat is real people rise up
and in situations like this where the
the fear has spread to a real threat to
the point that the reaction does not
match the threat mm-hmm and you know
from the times you've done where you've
been in crisis counseling with folks
you've been in situations like that do
you see that people have a tendency just
the human-animal has a tendency to do
that I think you just said it best it's
you kind of devolve to your animal
instincts right which is to either say
all the information we're getting stupid
or all the information we're getting is
the right
thing or I'm gonna start buying toilet
paper as they were having a mass
diarrhea epidemic right I mean it's this
people are responding irrationally right
absolutely dysentery is not one of the
symptoms not one of the large not one of
the things one of the things it's not
what's causing it but I have no idea but
and water it being in the water system
is not one of the methods that a couple
of weeks ago when it started sell our
water and get the bottle it's got a hose
I don't I don't know I just don't get it
what are you doing if there was a run on
meat or vegetables I'd make I could go
with that or a run on vitamin C water
water
I got a sink man I got a bathtub I mean
we're yeah as if the public water supply
was going to get tainted who knows what
again is going through people's minds
nothing nothing nothing good yeah
nothing thoughtful I guess so how do you
um talk to your teen right now your
college student that has been infected
by this fear and help them have the
wisdom to address the actual threat
without an overreaction
I'll default back to another thing we
learned in crisis counseling which is
facts are your friends
be honest be straightforward be direct
which is we've never experienced this
before some people are saying this some
people are saying this some people are
telling us to this and in this house
here's how we're gonna handle it right
and be pretty clear I think having a
plan for the next couple of weeks on
here's what our days are gonna look like
here's how hard we're gonna interact
with each other here's how we're gonna
honor one another here's how we're gonna
limit our screen time in the house I
think there's all kinds of things we can
do but you got to be intentional same as
you would start in a business the same
as you would trying to have a great
marriage you got to be intentional okay
to your friends new Ramsey personality
dr. John Delaney joining us we're
talking from his perspective
with a doctorate in counseling about the
fear and the anxiety that's out there
right now the panic this out there the
hysteria this out there how to deal with
it personally how to deal with it down
phone number here's triple 8 8 to 5 5 2
to 5 back with your calls